olympics organizers are meeting to
address increasing pressure for the
games to be cancelled
one of the official partners the asahi
shimbun newspaper is warning about the
dangers of the coronavirus
and pointing to the widespread public
opposition last week a union
representing medics
said it strongly opposed the event which
is scheduled to start in less than two
months
only around two percent of japan has
actually been vaccinated
we'll talk about this with jeff kingston
now in tokyo he is the director of asian
studies at
temple university japan um
jeff does anyone want these games to go
ahead
the government seems determined so
damn the torpedoes full speed ahead and
uh the people are scratching their heads
why
um only 14 percent of japanese
favor hosting the games and about 80
percent want them
postponed or canceled we have a who's
who
of ceos speaking out against the games
one of them called them a suicide
mission and all
public health experts believe that this
is recklessly endangering
the health of the japanese people so yes
there are good reasons why people wonder
why prime minister suga seems so
determined to go ahead
tell me about and tell our viewers
indeed about asahi shimbun the newspaper
how much influence does it hold
oh it's huge it's like the new york
times
of japan or the guardian um you know
it's highly respected
generally on the liberal side of the
spectrum
but the asahi you know has uh a stake in
all this and they've just
called out the authorities and said it
doesn't make
sense you know we're you know the
vaccination campaign here
the rollout has been a dribble only just
over
two percent of japanese have gotten
fully
vaccinated and this compares to like 40
percent in the us
34 percent in the uk so really japan is
a laggard on
vaccinations and suddenly they're going
to be bringing in 60 to 80
000 visitors from all over the world for
the olympics
you know there are good reasons people
believe this could potentially be a
super spreader event
starting to wonder if there's some sort
of misguided and that's my word
misguided uh
pride going on here the fact that the
games were cancelled last year
that they were put forward to this year
and it would just be some sort of great
symbol
for japan to show to the world that look
we can do this despite
all this opposition and and concerns
yeah i think you're right i think
perhaps there is some misguided pride
there i think that
also they want to hold the sort of
global
coming out party for the end of the
pandemic but a lot of people here
are worried that the declaring mission
accomplished a little bit too
soon i think more importantly is money
they've spent about 28 billion preparing
for the olympics
uh nbc has paid 3 billion to the ioc
for television rights and so money
is driving this decision and this seems
inconsistent with the olympic spirit and
that has caused
grave concern among the japanese people
who feel that they are being treated
like guinea pigs
so they are very skeptical about the
government's assurances that safety
protocols will keep them
safe and that they can conduct this
massive
uh games in a bubble a decision driven
by money who would have thought
jeff kingston thank you for your time we
appreciate it
all right thank you